tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa dj oggi siamo tornati
sudafricane the floor i gelsi come
ragazzi avete detto questo gioco mi
mette tranquillità una cosa del genere
dell'ultimo vito tutti non avete detto
ho deciso di giocarla in pigiama
ok perfetto perché i ragazzi ci vuole
atmosfera in questi giochi cioè se non
ha senso
eravamo rimasti qui cioè io io non so
neanche perché cazzo sfrontato una che
spuntano gli alberi puntano gli altri
che bello ragazzi io ho sbagliato
mestiere devo fare il giardiniere perché
paraguay sono troppo avanti devo capire
perché vi spuntano agli ar va bene un
importo è entrato in una finestra quindi
[ __ ] devo dire ragazzi che
dall'ultima volta che ho provato a
giocarci è stato tanto ce l'ho fatta a
superare ostacoli in modo incredibile
per l'ultima volta essere giocato
ragazzi cos'è cos'è sto coso che cazzo
così starò monster per ora il drago
scena ho trovato un drago share non raga
non ho capito perché è però va bene
torno giù tra l'altro io vado torno
nella finestra che mi fa abbastanza
schifo perché il drago sharon entrato in
in un barile sono successe troppe cose
che non mi spiego quindi ragazzi andiamo
avanti perché non ha senso avete adorato
sto gioco più di quanto pensassi o poi
capraia yo no no no davis all
ecco perché non mi piaceva sentite
porchi attrae ma ci fece saltare
allora o niente dopo una sega di una
sedia faccia negli esperimenti per
vedere se il gioco vi piace o no
c'è
e sorprendentemente ragazzi vi è
piaciuto anche se è un po diverso dai
soliti giochi che faccio non so perché
mi hanno mandato io continuo a morire
però c'è il drago shenron quindi
resuscito ogni volta non ha capito bene
il senso di sparare su due draghi che
faccio a presenta posso entrare nello
spazio grazie molto gentile vi
ricordiamo ragazzi viaggi interstellari
confavi j scontati del 25 per cento
quindi affrettatevi un ragazzo e mi ha
scoperto che sono bravo nel mestiere del
giardiniere c'è una cosa che mi riesce
proprio devo andare avanti no no tua
sorella tagliaerba devo ancora capire il
senso di tutto questo comunque però
ancora ok ok io sto entrando in finestra
è diventato strano sto gioco dall'ultimo
episodio perché non ho capito bene il
senso dove sto andando naga dove cazzo
sto andando io non sto capendo strada
sbagliatissima mi sa
ecco no io continuerò così per molto
tempo ma ed eccoci siae ho trovato ma
basta draghi io non ho capito cosa mi
sono sti draghi sharon sull 20 c e d
puzzette qualsiasi cosa siano non lo
capisco la mia teoria questa quel no la
mia teoria essere un [ __ ] nel
cervello questa mia teoria vorrei capire
un attimo perché ci sono si contanto
questa mi sembra la nuvola sfidi di goku
adesso almeno due c'è un'altra figlia io
sto entrando ragazzi non in finestre a
caso non sta neanche capendo io devo io
devo trovare tanti di questi cosi
sarebbe qui si è già fatta e adesso ne
ho tre ragazzi diventeremo un esercito e
tribuna adesso vanno tutti gli
fantastico quanti se va bene servono 45
cazzo chiede un prestito non ci sono
andati da ecco perché no
calmi tutti calmi che con la calma si
risolve tutto si risolve tutto si
risolve un cazzo con la calma e l'uomo
donne di quel no no non puoi far ma
perché salti come un cerebroleso non ha
senso sono io non ho capito il perché si
e dandole hub di blood a si no non
mancate
non me lo sto continuando a mancare
adesso l'ho presa di qua ci sono già
stato però sono andato di sopra quindi
adesso vado qui ok no che hai una sega
qualcuno di voi mi spiega come un essere
umano potrebbe mai arrivare a qualcosa
ma io non so
non sono mano io sono otto non
preservativo non sono morto anche solo
un preservativo non cambia niente
capiranno mai ci passava sotto sifas
anche il drago tra ok ok per dirlo prima
io che ne so ho fatta tra l'altro ne ho
22 trovarne ancora uno mi pare vecchi
artisti due draghi di merda eccolo lì ci
siamo
sono entrato nell'altro spazio adesso mi
mi fate capire a parte fare il
giardiniere qual è il mio scopo in
questo gioco non perché sono due episodi
che lo faccia l'ascensore
ho trovato la scienza ragazzi si siano
perché ragazzi negli ascensori i moderni
non si usa più il tasto per chiamare
l'ascensore ma bisogna portare i draghi
i draghi perché se non funziona allora
ho messo due pallini su qualcosa mi
manca un orrendo che sia di qua ragazzo
spero ragazzi che sia di qua perché sono
l'unità è come effetto ho trovato ho
trovato un accesso ce l'ho fatta adesso
devo andare
siamo nel mondo di barbie ragazzi sta
cosa è bellissimo solo che non ho capito
che si può notare che figo non c'è più
lo stile rana non c'è più ostile libera
ma c'è lo stile preservativo che questo
quanto cazzo e veloce tosto condom a
nuotare 109 incredibile vabbè andiamo
avanti perché non ho capito il senso di
suo livello però è rosa l'obiettivo di
suo livello e trovare ma ci si cresce
che figura adesso posso saltare anche al
contrario va beh se la cosa è troppo
bella fa diventando la figata pazzesca
auto già che avete pazienza sono che
hanno capito perché ci sono i pesci che
adesso ragazzi sono passato al mestiere
del giardiniere a quello del pescatore
bellissimo si è fatta ci ha fatto
perfetto
calmiamoci un attimo che devo capire
cosa devo fare è ok ok ok mica io sono
troppo germano muovono ragazzi ci provo
però non non ne ho idea dalla femmina
attimo se minchia troppo troppo forte o
forte oggi è così capiamoci perché non
so dove sto andando ancora mie mi è
difficile capirlo nuova gamma e va beh
allora sinistra a di qua che figo
se già fatta ciò fatta bellissimo
bellissimo sono troppo belli io sono
troppo beh qualche faccia sexy al
contrario ragazzi dovete capirmi si
impappina al cervello io non capisci che
culo
papi nel cervello io stento riesco a
farlo da dritto cazzo figuriamoci al
contrario di qua è giusto che io sto
facendo giusto a caso cioè non so
neanch'io come ok ok adesso dovrei
saltare ma sto cazzo come la spiega poi
come faccia saltare [ __ ] il deve
visto già perché dovrei farmi chilometri
ogni volta che muoia è fantastico ma non
si può passare la sopra sicuro si no
quando lasciano quasi non ce la farò
invece sì sì sì se dio santo ragazzi con
questi pesci che girano sotto prima poi
mi spunta uno squalo a caso mi fa il
culo ma convinto proprio madonna che
salto ma basta troppo figlio con questo
gioco vado al contrario perché ci sono
delle pareti gelatinose perché io muoio
[ __ ] stipe è il bay che facevi piano
per il culo perché vi sembra che si sia
fatta pace tra un pò capovolgo lo
schermo e quando quando vado sott'acqua
giro al monitor così almeno vedo dritto
perchè non riesco a capire veneto
perfetto guarda che riguarda chiaro ma
guarda che roba
se l'ho preso purtroppo trovato
l'ascensore ho trovato il [ __ ]
ascensore sono tre ragazzi siamo
scappati dal mondo di barbie è stata una
cosa brutta che se noi abbiamo
sbloccarlo adesso so tre palle non
fraintendete o tre palle per quindi
posso entrare nell'ascensore tratto
quelle povere rane sono rimaste da sole
sono sbloccato di posta cosa cosa che è
successa ecco le rane ci sono le rande
cosa che succede di preciso dove entrare
la ciao ragazzi concludo quindi non c'e
lancio al monito avete fatto la li na na
na con questa bellissima canzone di
sottofondo che non è una canzone ma
sembra tipo un flauto in defecazione
lasciato come te mi piace anche a faccia
di facebook e come ogni video trovate la
descrizione sortite prestiti scrive the
rich e uno prossimo vino spero di
riuscirci belle ragazze